planet Earth is the home of every
life-form known to us in the universe
its age is about a third of the age of
the universe and admitted it is a thing
of beauty a slightly squashed fair with
a heavy metal core and a lighter surface
crust wrapped in a thin sliver of sweet
air to breathe with vast oceans fertile
plains magnificent mountains freshwater
rivers streams lakes and aquifers
orbiting a star which warms us and gives
us energy but how did our home come into
existence and what's it made of 4.6
billion years ago earth was created from
the remnants of dead stars that
collected in a giant dirty gas cloud the
gas cloud became denser in its center
and formed the chrétien disk small
particles started clumping together and
building larger and larger objects until
they formed the objects we call planets
today this process took 10 to 20 million
years and is still not very well
understood at about this time when the
solar system was young and chaotic a
giant object about as big as Mars
collided with our home
the impact was violent and if the object
had been more massive it might have
destroyed earth material from earth was
smashed out into orbit and formed the
moon which is the biggest satellite in
relation to its planet in the solar
system
at this time Earth was a hot hell
constantly being hit by asteroids with
seas of lava and a toxic atmosphere but
something was about to change
drastically earth cooled down water from
the inside of the earth wandered to the
surface and rained down on earth only to
vaporize again and become clouds
millions of asteroids brought more and
more water to our planet all the water
on earth has about this volume compared
to earth today the surface of earth is
71% water and 29% land 97.5% is say 9
water while only 2.5 percent is fresh
water the fresh water is 69 percent ice
and snow 30 percent our ground waters
and only about 1% make up the remaining
ground waters but even this small part
is mostly frozen only a tiny part of our
water is actually lakes and rivers and
an even tinier part is bound in living
things so gradually the earth cooled
down and the surface formed a thin crust
but inside the earth hot rock continue
to swirl about moving the crust from
below and breaking it apart this process
is called plate tectonics and is
happening right now we'll make a whole
video about it in the future for now
let's just say that the crust of Earth
consists of separate giant plates that
move around as they meet they crumble
and create mighty mountains or violent
plunge back down deeper into earth
creating deep trenches that's the way
the highest place on earth was formed
Mount Everest and the deepest the
mariana trench from our perspective
Earth's mountains and trenches are
mighty indeed but when you look at the
earth in cross-section you can see how
tiny they actually are the part we stand
on is the crust which is about 50
kilometers thick though it can vary
between 5 and 70 kilometers by the way
the deepest hole ever drilled by man is
12 point two six two kilometers deep
after the crust comes the mantle it's a
silicon rocky shell and about 2900
kilometers thick the mantle consists of
the upper mantle and the lower mantle
the upper mantle has different regions
to its upper part which is viscous and
carries the crust is called the
lithosphere after that there comes the
asthenosphere which consists of less
mobile mostly solid material the lower
mantle reaches deep down to the outer
core of Earth Earth's outer core is a
liquid layer of iron and nickel about
2266 kilometers thick temperatures vary
from 4,000 degrees Celsius to 5700
degrees Celsius and in the center is the
inner core it's mostly solid the ball
made of an iron nickel alloy with a
radius of about 1,200 kilometers 70% the
size of the moon and about the
temperature of the surface of the Sun it
is slowly growing at an estimated rate
of about one millimeter per year
now for some perspective this small
layer of crystallized milk products of
former molten mantle is where we live
then there's Earth's magnetic field it's
an invisible phenomenon that diverts
high-energy particles coming from the
Sun and other sources allowing for a
stable environment with comparatively
little radiation impact on earth but why
is it there actually we don't really
know a terrible lot about that we know
it has something to do with the core of
the earth inside this metal sphere large
electrical currents flow in complicated
patterns they cause a magnetic field
that sort of stabilizes itself according
to the laws of electrodynamics this
entire system is called the dynamo
but don't let us fool you into thinking
we have it all figured out speaking of
breathtaking information what about the
airy stuff that surrounds us by volume
dry air consists mostly of nitrogen
oxygen argon carbon a variable amount of
water vapor and small amounts of other
gases humans are very dependent on the
lowest layer of the atmosphere the
troposphere where the weather is it's 12
kilometers thick on average above that
is the stratosphere which is where the
ozone layer protects us from the sun's
most aggressive type of light above that
is the mesosphere the coolest place on
earth with an average temperature around
minus 85 degrees Celsius as about 80
kilometers up the thermosphere starts
the transition to space is a fluent one
without clear borders but humans decided
that space starts here at about 100
kilometers earth stops and space begins
though the atmosphere extends a bit
further in this region we find the
ionosphere the aurora borealis and the
ISS then the outermost layer is the
exosphere stretching up to ten thousand
kilometres it merges fluently with outer
space where there's no atmosphere at all
the atoms and molecules in this area are
so far apart that they can travel
hundreds of kilometres without colliding
with each other okay
humans in their present form have only
been around for 200,000 years
that's 0.004 percent of Earth's history
not long really and here we are now
living in a thin moist layer on a small
wet rock we call this rock earth it is
the product of the universe's deepest
workings the result of a constant
process of creation and destruction
happening all over the universe all the
time
helped by chance the laws of the
universe and random events we are really
lucky
[Music]
you